they know all right we are live
flashpoint eat boxes what's going on man
um you know just got a nice little
workout in but we get closer and closer
to forsaken and it doesn't feel like
it's two months away with everything we
keep gettin I mean I look over in at
7:12 them like this is September when
this thing comes out we got I got some
time so it seems like it should be
sooner but just you know gotta read that
I've trained just a little bit longer
yeah that's a good point man it you
forget like we still a little bit we
still a bit of ways you know it's just
like to get all this information early
it's kind of interesting but I'm not
opposed it's just saying it
no no I'm enjoying it Thanks
so we got on the docket man you know
what to talk about we are going to try
and make this a reasonable time frame
for you guys last week was insanely long
you know it was a bunch of stuff to
cover so being said we want to try to
make this a bit more of a somewhat
guided path through our thoughts so yeah
the first thing shout out to Guardian
con that stream was for one crazy there
were some huge records some moments in
there but 2.7 they did it
to run that's that hospital for a day
and they did it tremendous tremendous
bro like it cannot be understated like
it is just one of those things that it's
like you know say what you want about
destiny the game itself yeah but there's
no better community I'm sorry and call
me biased like having million for
charity and this thing just keep getting
bigger and bigger the st. Jude thing and
like it's all for a good cause and at
the end of the day like I said we
started when we started flashpoint you
know Guardian con is kind of like the
history of me anybody's really that's
our history like that's our foundation
if it wasn't for that event I don't meet
this man everything like like our
passion for this game extends to that so
it's very special to me but at the same
time
it's just a positive thing you know I'm
saying just well good cause and I've
never seen the game really do anything
like that man it's definitely commended
I'm very proud you know of the community
and it turnout and the CDs numbers and a
CEO these guys do the he's like he'll if
you guys hit this amount you go to
Bungie devs and stuff you know say hey
we've got pokken Patrick getting but
matching art but cats is amazing
Lupo get three hundred and fifty
thousand or something in the middle of
history
ninja got $100,000 anonymous donation
which everybody's guessing is like epic
games for for links all Mina who doesn't
matter who does it I was watching bro
man it's like a bun she's like here's a
thousand from the dev team here's the
thousand from The Guardian contine
here's the thousands and they were just
jumping that they probably did like
seven thousand because sevens their
number but I mean it was just it's
amazing like it's just kind of Awesome
so proud of the community man
well it really does it really goes are
out there at Guardian con shake some
hands meet some cool people play game
but for me I'm jealous but I go meet
some awesome people there's a bunch of
cool people just shake hands say hello
and you know just celebrate that Gaming
is doing good things
so absolutely mm-hmm
great great stuff man but we have to
start with that one just because that
was amazing I kind of kept following us
throughout the week as it kept building
seeing some of them like that's the
community podcast poke bear about lost
this stuff dad oh and dad I went triple
wreck we're doing their thing it was
cool seeing the numbers that would pop
up you're like hey who's the streamer
hey out they do old man 76,000 all
hundreds I like in there so oh it was
really really so yeah shout out to that
stuff but let's get into twelve deeds
actually coming out of hiding writing
the helm the agent of building here in
time well if you guys have been playing
iron banner it's kind of low-key this
week there is one more in August they
have confirmed there will be at least
one more coming but 66 6v6 is gonna be
all the time in quick like coming next
week so that patch 1.2.3 is on the way
a stickman six we said should be part of
the quick play casual lift I have
absolutely no problem
I mean it was cool that it was reserved
to iron banner but it's also dope that
now quick play gets that fold it's
really cool yeah but Rumble is also
coming as a permanent playlist and then
you know they're given some other stuff
to work on so one thing they've still
kind of kept fairly vague mmm bout two
full harvest those bounties yes
now bounties were just a nice thing
because I haven't noticed myself doing
it the other day I was just doing strike
challenges and then all of a sudden a
challenge pops up I never check them but
randomly I sometimes just do them
something about bounties like going and
being like okay it's like I want to go
you know it's like I got something to
work on I'm gonna go wander on a planet
I'm gonna switch it makes me play
different subclasses it makes you do
different things so I don't they don't
go into too much detail we know there's
probably gonna be some crucible we know
there's probably gonna be some out in
the world they said there's gonna be
different vendors they're gonna have
them so I mean who all do you think
you're gonna have these cuz I mean this
is pretty forsaken so where do you think
getting these from yeah you know
obviously with obviously is the
obviously ones to shacks this is a viola
pod with the Vanguard I'm curious if I
Cora get something because I know they
kind of got her stuck with her
meditation but I kind of feel that these
are revamp honestly so I wouldn't be
mind if they do something new with the
armor what I'm hoping for and I think I
take a good guess and obviously I'm a
little biased because I'm Osiris fanboy
but I'm hoping mercury mad brother Vance
gets up you know we got to do we got to
do something with the damn you know
round about so there's got to be a
reason to come back and the reason why
I'm guessing he'll get something is let
I think one point too quickly which
we'll get into he's getting a little
love for as far as arm weapons you know
as far as the arm the Osiris to forge
DeForge stuff yep so I'm just hoping
that you know again cuz obviously it's
one of the most you underutilized you
know based on the reception of the DLC
you know
yeah location so they really need to do
something with market and I'm hoping
that you know that that it's him so what
who you who do you think far as far as
vendor wise also get some love as far as
bounties I mean him alone but I probably
would say most of them I mean I'd like
to see Anna in dev room and all those
people just your faction vendors but
also just your location vendors but also
I mean I want to see like I want to see
shacks I want to see is alone
guys coming in to get just your you know
some of them have your strike bounty
some of them have your crucible bounties
and so they've said they will be
obtained from a variety of vendors so
that sounds like most of them probably
right the general reward XP which is
always good for those ever verse packs
you may as well get them for free and
cover the prismatic matrix and a little
bit nicer in reputation so keep getting
those levels and again if you're working
on bounties you're working on Zavala if
you want to get a little closer to that
you know level 50 you it's one quicker
way to get there and so as you know the
reason to run strikes and maybe again
like everybody runs strikes the same way
what if you need to go I need to get
Sentinel kills or something I'm gonna
run void but I typically don't so we'll
see how much those sync up but should be
interesting they be able to be redeemed
in the field which is I'm glad they
brought that from the d2 we're doing
just like click on it done yeah yeah in
bounties like I said um share the
kabocha who used to hate the old d1
Bonnie system but what I do miss about
it is just like it gave you like I said
you play different you had more of a
structure I think with the new system
what tends to happen is I don't check it
as much like the left trigger and you
know it kind of takes me out of you know
my whole gameplay pattern so I kind of
like just looking at you know grabbing
them up and you know the cool thing is
from what I understand you still should
you still should be able to cash them
out wherever you out like you don't have
to like do the old d1 of your bring it
back and then you know I'm saying that
was annoying so at least they fixed as
aspect of it and I'm excited even
curious to see as far as rewards because
you know exotic route he's got to be
thrown in here somehow ok we're getting
to that you're one they said there are
two new
can expound ease will expire if left
uncompleted now some may be daily bounty
so that's really understandable you
can't just like carry him over
acquiring them we'll have a little bit
of glimmer so I mean they're giving you
some reason to have glimmer and keep
laying he they said they wanted to avoid
the grab everybody and you know until
your inventories packed right so I'm
gonna have a specific purpose go grab a
couple go do this you know maybe head
back could do this but they also said
the in forsaken more vendors will offer
more bounties and some will provide
legendary or better being a exotics
hahaha words for completing them so it's
fair to observe here that we didn't they
didn't answer that many questions they
don't to spoil them so they've got him
come in and again this may be like
Downey's point nine and they may kind of
take little thoughts and do kind of more
of a day one patch for forsaken for any
to become comes to it so again
constructive criticism one she listens
to that stuff but don't really go they
like I mean that's that's sometimes what
you just kind of jump to be like all
these are terrible Downey's yeah like
beta bounties like will get 0.9 in there
and then we might even or more so if you
feel like this should be more or
specific or more vendors make it home
just do it in a nice way
absolutely lungs like I say they take
any feedback so it's cool and this is
something that we also wanted and just
I'm just curious to see how the the XP
and reputation systems and reward
systems to completely work once we get
them out in the field but it's good to
have them back in also more sources of
ways to kind of level so that's always
good in my peer yeah it's just nice to
have a little variety of stuff to do and
it's one of those things I was surprised
they didn't care you know it was been
there for d1 for three years then all of
a sudden no bounties on my call yeah I
was like it's not something I ever
thought I would miss and then all the
sudden I was like yeah so what I did
remember we were both surprised when
they came out we saw that term the term
on on the devil calendar yeah okay cuz
yeah I mean I didn't hear a scream
before so it was really cool see them
bring it back I got um I might for it
yeah I think this is just a little more
into the fact that like I don't know
destiny to year one I feel like it was a
rushed and they're slow like okay there
should have been in there let's get that
Meritage I ate it all right this should
have been in there that in there okay
check like they're just working back
through things that they just didn't
have time for it's really weird so yeah
for what else is coming again guarding
Kahn if you're out there enjoy it say
hey two people should be a great time
again they've got some huge people out
there I don't know if ninja is actually
gonna be at that thing but I know they
got fortnight involved they got warframe
involved they guys and Destiny's finally
in a good place that it's going to be
involved you know like I was thinking
before like when I had my I had a ticket
for it I was thinking about going and
timing-wise this what would you close to
a vacation but it felt like destiny too
was like not in good spirits so they
were looking at other stuff cuz they
didn't have the hype behind dusty now
the four seconds in a good place
and gambits there and all that appeals
there it's but like at the time I was
absolutely I mean let's be our full
transparency more cognitive like that
was a major part of the decision process
I mean cuz when these tickets go on sale
y'all you know it's way ahead of time
this was during the complete death
period that the game had no pulse
people were raging leaving you know exit
you know exiting the ship like the
Titanic yeah I'm sitting and I'm just
like man I just didn't have the
enthusiasts usually hasn't old man
obviously financially you know I had a
lot of things going on this year with
different events and so I did want to
cut so many conventions going on like
man you know crazier yeah it was just
too much and I said you know what the
fact I think the fact that destiny
wasn't doing good at well as kind of
like was the season to you but yeah but
now I feel it because it's turned around
and you know you I am feeling a little
bit right now like damn and like it
would have been cool and obviously a lot
of close friends of mine you know cactus
HD and Fall Out plays you know I've seen
the pictures one person I never got a
chance to meet I met by but one person
I'm a big fan of is an unknown player
yes yeah like he's dad I never met him
the other time if not known if he went
the other times but you know this time I
know for a fact he was there and I'm
like
I know chop it up wouldn't know like
that's my do right there so you know a
little regret buyer's remorse right now
but I still think it was a good call
for my wallet right now it's like not it
doesn't work for everybody every year I
mean people like jazz he's coming from
Australia wherever he's coming from so
not everybody can make it but yeah maybe
we'll see if we can you know if we keep
this thing going I'd have to make a
special appearance next year if we can
you know keep this train going on
destiny to being a a good thing yes
patch 1.2.3 it's coming we've talked
about crucible changes like 6v6 and the
way they're switching control and what
they're basically going to we'll get to
those Game Informer articles in a little
bit yes sir we've got a little bit of
patch notes and then just some kind of
quick brief overview stuff about oh yeah
strikes so we'll get to that in a second
but the quality of life changes like PC
chain clan that's coming as you said the
mercury forged weapons if once they've
all been obtained so once you've gone
through the full thing you've got your
goal that it'll be available for direct
purchase so whether if you delete it or
didn't quite get it or something like
that you'll be able to pick it up
they're taking momentum out of heroic
adventures it's like when you're running
on your Titan and you're like we'll go
for that shoulder charge it feels like
it takes forever for that to activate
but it feels like it takes forever to
eat your hell it's not just moving
they're like yeah if I could just at
least be moving back and forth like
strafing you literally have to be like
full sprint for that race yeah good way
to hide you can so I just did one of
those three toes with them was it cots
and we use up me I was getting some done
cuz I was knocking out my um my what you
call it my Polaris Lance Quest yep and
I'm up to the three Vango so I started
doing it with van gogh's I'm like you
know what I didn't do the powerful gear
heroic strike for a week so I just
combined it they had that momentum or I
was so disgusting so far
that really will not miss it being gone
let it get out of it yeah
so that's being changed the pursuits
inventory like where you kind of watch
your quest in progress is actually going
to the top just a bad thing because
that's usually look for half the time
from check and stuff so and just in game
screens they're gonna just add commas in
there for better visibility on numbers
just simple stuff post kana support that
kind of data
got a couple exotic fixes targets being
marked by the single night alchemy when
you can see through walls they were also
producing orbs
I gotta kind of comment on that I just
started using that exotic and I'm
starting to understand the functionality
of it in a crucible like you can see the
walls with this thing this thing is is
savage for armed competitive and trials
it's really rough down bull I'm kind of
mad that I didn't know produced orbs as
a glitch go I didn't know that they said
star fire protocol does not work with
dawn blades attunement of the sky path
so I fixing that and then prevented the
Warlock melee damage when using Ophidian
aspect and hive sword just some couple
weird little glitches but we also have
strikes okay I don't know if you've seen
them I've thought about doing it but so
many people hate the strike strike
modifiers right now right I mean even in
the 113 questions or whatever they had
about dusty - they're like are you gonna
make heroic strikes easier are you gonna
make harder
I'm like those are like brutal questions
ask the dev straight up but it's like
knife holes aren't that hard heroic
strikes sometimes just kicking your butt
and also some of the modifiers a lot of
people have said they're not fun like
grounded you're going okay I literally
can't use half of my point of being
Guardian jumping exactly like how fun is
that like wait who said that was fun
well with moves like that memo ow yeah
let me run around oh you've got a fight
where you've got a giant worm that's
gonna light the ground on fire you have
to jump now yeah okay so no blackouts
another one I mean come on that was if
you're with a group it's fine that means
because you'll get it but I mean there
sometimes
you're doing trying to think which one
is the raid all one right but also the
lethal melee yes so it's like whether if
there's a like a bunch of thrall coming
at you or all of a sudden you don't
catch like the hive knight that spawns
off to the side and walks her in a
pillow and then smash you're dead like
it just sucks yeah sorry I mean it so
maybe those could be a bit harder on
nightfall but find a way to scale them
for heroics so folks aren't like the
most brutal thing ever mmm rough and
then glass is another one they're
working on so they said they want to
ensure enemies melees are still
threatening but they're like they
shouldn't just like you know if I'm 380
and the I'm runnin a 350 strike
shouldn't be a one-shot now if you get
like overrun by dogs yeah you're
probably gonna get taken out pretty
quick but if one dude punches you you
should survive now which seems a little
fare sadness I agree completely yeah
grounded one of the biggest things is
just if your fault your move if you're
in the air at all weather bump off a
ledge are falling down that extra damage
is so much yeah tone that to where you
know it's not quite as bad especially if
you're like falling from you know two
meters and getting just sniped yeah and
it could sit in that jumping like that's
that's way too punishing there's no
doubt yeah so that's getting a tweaking
glasses getting this week they'll have
more patch notes but just the fact that
they are addressing these somewhat I
wish they would honestly just kind of
get a little more creative or give us
more variety in some of these I'm gonna
miss the I miss even if it's like
kinetics or energies or they have the
heavy in there I'd like to just see a
little more push on the other weapons
just as variety as well what if it's you
know Precision's do double damage
energies do half or vice versa make you
play with specific guns like just have
that be I don't know I just like to see
more variety on that stuff still because
we just have the same three and all I do
is wait for heavy to show up still the
only way I do heroic strikes now you're
right that's absolutely I mean I said
that's a tried-and-true strategy so I
will agree with you on that knowing
you've thought process with this so it's
just kind of one of those where I wish
there was a little more variety I'm glad
they're starting to address it so we'll
see how these go but doesn't sound like
enough but as long as it's not quite as
brutal then at least with the buffs it
might be alright but
yeah just more variety I mean so what if
you had to make up one that helps you
one that hurts you just a couple strike
ideas strike modelers I'm not good with
this modify stuff yeah full disclosure
but that's kind of thing you put them on
the spot like okay how do you fix it
everybody's like uh you're right you're
right we're the first complain because I
met it and then so how do you fix it I'm
not the strike modify you do to be
honest I just deal with it right so it's
annoying momentum and glass and I just
do it I like my new things I just come
up with to kind of cheese but for any
most of the age they need to come up
with something that like I said from a
noose understand where that is again
punishing but not to the point of
complete frustration with like
borderline unplayable with certain
strikes you know that one one you
couldn't jump in with that what's that
one it ends I know the cheese how to
beat that well you can beat the Cabal
you fighting in a vex world he comes
crashing down he smashes effects oh yeah
like that one we don't even get to that
part you know I'm saying he'll start to
drool DJ said I love them strike mattify
is on my prestige knife was not trying
to grind out heroics anymore that [ __ ]
ain't like see my cheese like when it
before the cheese what we do is we fight
the strike normally he crashed on a guy
you beat him he runs then he gets to
that part with his - you know pits on
the side he just knocks you off and then
if you got if you got that stupid
modifier the minute you're in the air
you finished like so what that was my so
my things like you know I'm not dealing
with that we log out imma grab these
little faction boots he said oh yeah
country due to tether I got the Luna
faction boots with the solar burn I
believe this week and then we had our
home which is so done oh I had yet three
sleepless it was all he did not escape
that room we melted him sounds like yeah
we ain't even dealing with that other
night
but again it shouldn't have to come to
these extreme methods so right over I
don't go up a rail oh yeah so what if it
was just one of those where it's like
hey you've only got two varieties now
they'd have to fix it to fix the jungle
thing what if you've only got kinetic
and power just flat-out take a weapon
slot away don't hurt you but then you're
usually stuck with one type like it'd be
kind of an interesting twist so I don't
know just like I mean have like ten
different modifiers so it's not just
like the same for your rotations every
week I mean just you've got to have some
stuff that's out there just to give us
some variety
what if kinetic does more energy or what
remember once like even d1 had some
decent ones like matching energy shields
like I didn't love it but it actually
was a way that you had to think hard
light would come get used a little bit
more so just some more variety in there
I think would be really good so it's one
of those things that I think needs it
but it's kind of an interesting topic
next we got the prismatic matrix so I
mean strikes we know changers accumbens
we're waiting on patch notes we'll dig
into those next week yes sir but the
prismatic matrix enjoy it because it's
dropping off for a little bit mm-hmm so
if you got it unfortunately I think I've
got tokens that I can't even use right
now but yeah what do you what do you
generally think about the prismatic
matrix so far to be honest I actually
don't mind it um what will happen is I
usually have about three of them stored
run over the old you know lady tests and
see what's going on and I literally is a
confession I'll okay look forward to
death or get killed if they say they
like any type of like the transactions
right but low-key I'll be on my own emit
game like I'll be like in them honor and
certainly mostly that elude me
so our going to the present amounts okay
what you got this week okay boom all
right so I'll knock out and get my I
level up my engrams normally and then as
it gets closer I'm like you know what is
either this one or that one or you know
I'll try to guarantee the ones I want
and get stuff that way I think I got a
sleeper ornament that way and some other
stuff that I wanted and more that way so
I don't mind it you know so I guess what
they looking at right now trying to fix
it they're trying to like a drop viewer
duplicate items and give pleasure I mean
basically what they were trying to do
with it in the first place they were
testing it rest of the state of their
goals were give more players more
control how they earn ever verse for a
more predictable path each reach the
guaranteed specific items and drop fewer
duplicates and honestly the last few
weeks I've had almost everything checked
in to me tools like if you play enough
and you get enough of those you're gonna
get everything you're gonna be close so
they said this week the user
interference call specific attention to
the limited time feature to explain our
previous objectives in future it is a
once a week thing right the original
intent was to make the prismatic matrix
for kind of a special event
something to help players are round out
their collections as the odds of earning
items would elude them so thanks to some
good feedback for the new feature
they're gonna try and make it better and
they're gonna bring it back with
forsaken so I don't know if it'll be at
launch if not so it's probably gonna
drop off for the next you know six weeks
or so but honestly I'm the same way like
just the fact that there was one emote I
was missing and it was the hack the
warmind one and I was like I was like
the ones I'd like that led the close and
that was the only thing I was missing
and I had three stored up I got it and
I'm done and it was like and that was
one of those just by playing enough and
just by getting off engrams I crossed
most of those boxes off and I could
actually go for the one I want without
having to spend anything I was good so I
like it like I have no objection to it
and I know everyone hates tests but
honestly look at everything she's got
emotes yep transmat effects
shaders cosmetic armor ornaments it
doesn't change the game everything all
this stuff now the only closest thing
I've even got to it is my ghost now it
still doesn't change the game but if
this thing a load sorry hold on I'm
trying to pull up destiny out of manager
so I can actually get the info here okay
so it's on my other screen but I just
want to be able to read what it does my
one that has been the best gasps exotic
so the generate gunsmiths telemetry
which is so useless by the way that
doesn't matter either it's just like oh
here's another token almost all of them
can do that you know what I love is
detects caches
with it all yes the starmap shell yeah
it was X caches within 50 meter range so
I see them a lot more than I used to and
increase glimmer games so I mean it's
still minor yeah actually yeah I like
that though Klimek it was important -
but you know you keep grinding 50 meters
I see them so much more frequently than
I I just be driving around I just pop a
little more and it gets me to go out of
my way a little bit more it's minor
I mean it's felt like one token whoa I
mean the general seat but honestly
though it's like if you miss a chest or
don't quite see it it still doesn't
affect really anything so the whole
slipperiest they've never put anything
that weapons they're never put guns in
there than faxing with perks like the
hands in their ends like just stop
worrying about it like oh they're gonna
have microtransactions Lloyd buy this
stuff play the game and honestly I've
earned most of it absolutely I agree I
always felt the quote unquote
microtransaction in destiny has always
been overrated I've always thought
that's been way overblown the only time
I had to admit at least I felt d2 for
the most part the only time they kind of
drop the ball is when they kind of well
that's one so you know there was no way
I was missing at him I think I was I
gonna have to crucify me don't judge me
but the second one was when it's prime
time only times I have a problem with it
is like when they did oh I call her
festival of the cost like when this
thing's you accept phone buy-in from her
Dan I got a prompt even though it's
cosmetic I can't earn it in like that um
even though that was a dawning I guess
it was that's way they had to get they
were slapped a little bit but again not
that it broke the game just that there
was no way you can obtain it through
normal gameplay that's where I had it
yeah see I like the one that's like okay
so say you work a lot you don't have
that much time but there's something you
really really really want and you don't
quite have the time then you have the
option not required you have the
shouldn't buy it who should honestly
just be able to buy like the pieces
maybe for like 100 silver a piece or
something like that yeah but on the
other side if you like hey I'm gonna
probably be playing a lot this week
anyway probably gonna earn most of it
maybe I miss one but yeah just have a
way in game to earn that stuff give both
of us that's the same thing with the
iron banner emote to piss everybody off
and I kind of feel it is an emote again
there's so many emotes kind of woo but
just the fact that it was like this is
iron banner we all love iron banner and
there's no other way to earn it so I was
like did I really care to a point no
it's like no I didn't spend my money on
it but just the fact that you couldn't
earn something that is like tried and
true to our hearts in the world of iron
banner that kind of that stung and it
was just one of those and it was timing
was the biggest one that's when destiny
was down in the dumps and you're gonna
slap us with that you're like wrong
moment Matt mattock attack know what I
mean overall it's like I enjoy the fact
that prismatic Spivs me like a checkbox
and it's like and if I've got a three
that I've saved up and there's like one
there's three things left to uncheck but
there's one I really really want I'm
gonna get it back to work on earn and so
it's like I'm okay with it so whatever
if they just kind of give it a little
more of a tweak and keep it going where
it's going I'm fine with it just don't
just don't break it I agree I felt the
intent was fine as long as you play the
game you're gonna get this stuff and
this to me was more of an assistance to
a direct path of something you want
that's not like that
yeah it gives you a little variety gives
you not quite you know instant purchase
and you still get the bright dust and
stuff so I actually got one of the
random bright does like thousand bright
dust from it in one of those in guy got
the huge if the brightness is like oh oh
there we go
I didn't have that one it forever right
so it's just nice to have but yeah so I
mean for the tois they talk about the
Game Informer articles and we're gonna
cover a couple of those an image in
moments of triumphs are out there by the
way guys so yes how are you doing on
your moments by the way are you
basically ready I'm like I think this
one got which one I left there look at
my having a minute but um I got a lot of
this
and I'm so happy i prestige valor
because i knew that was gonna be
annoying now that i when i realized oh
that's part of the triumph as i let me
do this now with the triple xp weekend
because I was like ma'am it was just
like it was the kind of an easy chill
way to do it yeah because I was like
it's gonna be one of those things where
I'm gonna regret it outside of this
weekend doing it in level in the normal
way you know I'm saying as far as the
increases you know in rank so got that
done it's I think it's something like
like fragments or some things that I'm
missing yeah I'm gonna get a couple of
things on Mars I've got to get some of
the regional chests like couple things
actually gonna work on some videos for
those when I get to them I'll be
watching this video shop that video baby
this girl so cute up on the cell phone
drive it along a nice movie bonta's Bob
Roy's painting load into the rigs it's
gonna be up on your right-hand side
behind quarters like I mean that's just
that's how I do it drop it is very
victory but yeah I mean I just like it
kind of it's that manual checklist I
like that they kind of keep these going
so um honestly kind of looking forward
to having this in game though with it
like like the triumphs and the
collections and all the stuff that we
can work on so glad to see there dabble
in that again
but yeah the triple exp I got a feeling
they might do one or two more weeks of
that before we get around to forsaken
but as it was paired up with Bay him I
was like yep some grinding is gonna
happen oh yeah you know it so that's
mostly for the swab as you guys know
game informer keeps dropping some crazy
stuff man bombs first one is now we
talked about the supers last time but
I'm we're just gonna go and kind of go
through quick yeah touches on each one
and just kind of now that you've seen
them in action in the videos and you
guys can go back and watch the videos
the gifts will be up won't you guys just
to give me your thoughts on
you're not you guys I mean if in chat as
well we just want to go through and get
quick thoughts on each one now you kind
of seen him a little bit more in action
so hunter way of the current what do you
think yeah I like I like a lot yeah I
mean it's one of those things that um it
was good like you said to see it
visually right because that really gives
you a whole deal and I I just like that
you know the whole temper strike thing
you know the reload synergy with the
lightning weave and then that
electrifying the target stuff and um to
be honest I still think wait that
whirlwind guard when you do the you know
the man you block oh yeah man I think
that's gonna have so much fun allottee
and then if you just disengage you
triple arm damage with the with the
super you know listen I know I've been
speaking to some hunters actually I
should say some one hunter shut up
bloody knuckles uh-huh he's you know
he's in this like hunter I call hunter
Envy stage with all the other supers
like oh oh just got screwed and I'm like
look I get it you may have wanted more
flash right I get it you may say hey
this is just all schreiter again okay
fine but here's the in my opinion these
hunter supers have way more practical
functionality in a day-to-day use than
the other ones I'm not saying that the
other ones don't have some really cool
amazing things I'm not gonna say that
but I think the people who think that's
100 class new supers are not flashy when
you actually play them again I think
these things are gonna be way more
effective that's just math and it gives
you variety to each type I mean you've
got something where it's aggressive up
in your face and now you've got the
reflect damaged where you know if you've
got a boss dumping some stuff at you
well no game right back so it's like it
changes and I think that's what they
said the biggest thing if you watch this
video and they took whatever the class
was and whatever they felt that was
missing and trying to give you an
alternative trying to give you guys
another way to play with each in the
class that was a Liberty cool
yeah for me honestly just affect the
uppercuts in there that one actually is
one of the partners in the slide and
apply yeah just looks cool that's what
these gifts doing over and over but yeah
the whirlwind it's just cool you're like
oh crap moment all right spin spin spin
that's what as you said everybody's
going to private matches all right what
can we reflect we reflected boy bombs we
in trouble Oh
that'll be cool hunter I got to see the
knives a little bit we got a little
variety this but like on a boss they
look like they hard that was just about
to say that I'm calling you out
cuz main things I told I said listen you
remember when we read the Indian formal
article and listing within any visuals
we didn't see any video right I told my
said well you got all this stuff you the
hunter even though the Titan does this
dis dis enough the warlock summons you
know the realms of what it sounds
spectacular but I told him I said listen
man until we see those damage values
right until we see how effective these
things in the real world we can't get
caught up with the verbage right I saw
that hunter super yellow on that boss
precise and powerful Nova bomb and you
know quickly it's an offensive super
things that hunters kind of cry out
sometimes as far as you know your
ability to stuff and do that's that's
serious that is that that looks like a
high damage dealing super the way he
melted in that video I was like wow that
boss that's gonna be a problem
make notice now I was like also it was I
like how they described if it's one
target it pretty much will focus
everything on it but if there's like a
spread of enemies he's like it's gonna
be like 20 spread out so it's like it's
multifaceted for what you're facing
which was and did you read or watch the
video where they say like you can do it
and shoot from and forward and then
shoot from behind this I'm like if your
sensitivity is high enough it's like
once like turn around and see if you can
hit one behind
yeah it's it's gonna take it might you
know like if you go like two in front
you can get left and right and hit them
both like it quick so mmm-hmm
again next is way of a thousand cuts
oh that's the gunslinger so night side
are way way the race no it's right it's
right
it's definitely right yeah man that one
that one's being too spectral blades
you got your basically whip out your cap
Atanas katanas going visible you know
next mess some people up looks cool man
and remember the key thing to with young
to gaining true sight invisible sight
with just a precision again I'll kill
with full how do you know how easy that
is to proc precision kills like bro got
rifles hand cannons and hunters are just
gonna be walking around think about
crucible tool precision kill boom you're
visible automatic right and true sight
knowing where everything it come on
again bloody knuckles I'm calling you
out again these are powerful amazing
things and crazy synergy crazy crazy
yeah I mean you've got the curse of
smoke bum we were running it's actually
a line of smoke so it's more like a
smoke wall which is cool you've got
these shattering strike perk that you'll
weaken them with reducing their damage
output like there's a lot of good things
in there for hunters they may be a
little more on the subtle side but I
mean they literally wanted the whaler if
they wanted you to be a ninja in a way
to rate this a cheat code so Titans next
one we got you know now I got to see
what this shield this walking shield
looks like look at the circumference
ahead I know it's pretty cool you can
stack like a good three or four people
behind you fire and through it as you
walk through facing a boss just good
stuff man they're you know making that
one now the other cool and they really
talk
about in the video is now we got to see
the detonators so like you hit somebody
with a detonator you tagged it you start
exploding it and if it's a group of
enemies and that one explodes then
there's more so I want to see how
somebody's like I want to see esoteric
like with like a mob after all hit that
one detonators they spread and spread
like he's just gonna have an awesome
like little montage oh no then you've
got way of the missile I still love how
this is called code of the missile not
like code of the yeah like something
like this
cold stuff up code of missile code of
flying explosion man they wanted to get
like instead of a roaming super it's
just one but dude when they land this
thing I mean I know they're hitting weak
enemies but they're doing a hundred and
thirty four thousand damage when they
land this thing
I mean being as it's not roaming and you
can't keep hitting that super it has to
be big oh that smells like I hope the
damage is matching and the other cool
thing jump up in the air hit your melee
smash the ground faster I love that so
it's like a little mini super all the
time yeah shout to the UM fight scene
check I spoke I believe it was all my
boy Finnegan who we play gambit with at
e3 um he said that when you jump in the
air the only thing with that super it
plays different because you won't be
able I believe you won't be able to
escape with that class oh yeah you lose
that charge and that mobility so you
play it's a different place now but he
said it's one of those things it's out
to Steve were you like you have to gonna
get adjusted to it but once you get it
down and have that functionality with
the UH melee you know it's gonna be
situational for certain sometimes you're
gonna want to pick a class that you want
to be able to move around but it's
different in place different mana and a
lot of people dig it still nice then we
get code of the Devastator though two
things a throwing hammer you can pick up
and I like how in the video is like no
my hammer I got to go get it it was just
funny how people really do not want to
leave their hammers but if you hammer go
pick it up hammer go pick it up like
it's gonna be just usable all the time
and there's just the fact that you it's
a video
yeah and she's a giant hammer smashing
fire tornado still awesome I just know
it gives the whole a Thor and Milton
mill there are kept announcer Sam gives
me that whole fantasy like go to him it
drops down you go get it you guys they
can get your power back like if they
really tapping into you know Thor Marvel
you know University III like the talk
across sounds still and just a melee
that you can throw at somebody that it's
gonna make the Titan play very
differently very cool indeed
so next we got the warlock dawn dawn
blade a two-minute of grace and this is
I hope they start going a little farther
into this because you want to know how
you now the only thing about a healing
grenade as I was wondering you never see
your buddy's health yeah that's gonna be
a joke yeah yeah it's not like World of
Warcraft I have my health beaters up top
I know who I need to throw in at you
don't have a way to know just to throw a
healthcare name now they said there's
one where you could drop on the ground
it can get picked up you can throw at
others and kinda gets like an area and
if you're doing like group damage you
can definitely be like hey you know do
we need health to like heal through this
right now let me just keep throwing your
names on the ground whatever it is it's
just kind of one of those that I'm not
entirely sure when it comes to that type
of stuff it's gonna work no that that's
a fantastic point I mean this is beyond
just a perfect Sherpa class you know
some people I know you running a strike
and some blueberries messing things up
you don't say like you could definitely
help the crew out you help the fire team
out that is a great point on energy
maybe there's something in place that
while you have the class or maybe at the
minute you charged a grenade it gives
some type of health indicator because
like you said how are you didn't know
you know who's really hurt and who's in
need so that that's a valid point but I
mean I almost need to put like green
health bears bars on there with people
so you're gonna say watch because
otherwise I'd be thrown person so this
is one of those things coming from a MMO
that you
I get a question about but let me just
the well of Radiance smash your sword
down big circle of extra damage extra
heat like healing and just start melting
stuff yeah that'll be here absolutely
now 2 min of the storm color mm-hmm
interesting um just wanted to say back
up one second this with the wall radius
well of leadings which I did play and um
go to e3 that's actually healing rift
and empowering rift in one rift yeah
yeah that's ridiculous
you're not sick so I just want to put
that out there with that but now if we
want to you said a 2 min of the grace
now this is the arm not said I was don't
blame the other one was the new one so
there's no one is a 2 min of control
control right this is interesting you
know saying like the little dark energy
thing you know on the ground
ionic traces that we hear like a mass of
the world stuff and then they bring him
back pulse wave pulse wave was an old um
passive that when it went with slum call
that pretty much very good in PvP or and
just in gentleman you got your health
low back to your your speed and help you
get get out of danger very quickly it's
like you became more agile so that was
cool I believe they had a low recovery
burst with it in the indeed one so I
don't know if they bring that part to it
as well but I've missed pause way pulse
rate was very underrated really helps
your team and then you got this ball
lightning thing right range yeah still
got a DA but still wanna know what their
this is about you know saying that you
know you kind of produce that projectile
that shoots out lightning gotta see how
that goes that like a small like how you
can floating fireball thing looks weird
yeah I gotta see how that's actually
functional but that Superman that chaos
read that that comic ami ha would just
hold it down oh it just looks like boss
melter it looks like boss melter and and
also you know the ultimate ability of
just stopping it that is cool
that's this first one you can do that
like save half of it oh yeah and that
way it gives you an option to use it
more often because and you melt a room
and you're done save
but no and you could just you have to
just wait for it to timeout and you're
good and you're done and I'm thinking of
something like that they're tuning which
is on the crest of the crown of Tempest
and that's a that's something that's all
about building your super energy up
right there's a parrot comparing it with
that class and just keep getting your
super over it like it so it's gonna be
interesting on balance because I believe
what are the dev said yeah this one
might break the game you just like we
might but I kind of like the bravery in
them in now since the turnaround in d2
with something they like you know what
let's just leave it in this so think I
wonder how much it takes off when it
starts cuz think about like hey if
you're about to face so many pvp and
just fire it's probably gonna melt them
pretty quick pretty wait and then just
wait for you to come back like you could
might be able to pop this thing on and
off fairly fairly quickly so I think in
PvP they may have to lessen it make it a
little bit stronger than maybe like a
prometheus lens or a cold heart where
it's not you're still like a second or
no instant melt it can't be instant
because if it's instant it you know you
can like you just potentially always
could have it especially if people
arrange I just thought about it though
if you pop it off is it have we have
confirmation and if you pop it off you
can pop it back on me maybe no but I
think you'd have to turn it off and get
it back full again maybe but yes they
have to balance it that way yeah like
you'd have to get it back a little bit
but it that way you'd still have it more
frequently yes most of the time if I'd
like somebody using building gun then
probably gonna go blow off six shots on
one maybe two people like you pop it on
pop it off and you still have like three
quarters on the left it's gonna be that
quick you know I still do you're right
it's still effective still absolutely
and then final one void attunement of
fission so this is ninja warping
explosion men yeah the possibilities I
want to see how powerful that explosions
gonna be yeah it also seems to have like
a mini devout
a little charge I want to see that and
um I just got see how it works is it
something that the explosion is
instantaneous can you control when you
do it do you have to blink a bunch of
times a certain amount of time then it
does it you know I can see a covering
ground I can see in me a real evil in
PvP I can I'm just visualizing banner
control point six Guardians they're
trying to think about it that will avoid
team shots it's like boom you explode
yeah delay but if you're in there you're
probably good so see how that works but
I'm going back to what I said last week
they're gonna make sure they buff those
other ones cuz all these are smoking the
current supers I haven't heard I haven't
heard a mention about oh by the way yeah
we're looking at the other supers if
we'll see it wait they would be you
would never play them say one of
forsaken I still think those old ones
are exactly as they are saying so that
pretty much covers the supers we kind of
just wanted to touch on those quickly we
are excited I've trained as rolling
holes on that fire visuals - yeah yeah
that was nice just to be able to see
them all specifically man he was so cool
I was new skier somebody shot him it's
like dude shout out to him just cuz yeah
he was absolutely loving every minute of
that explanation cuz you know he's out
there like he was like the developer of
the supers and he was just loving
talking about it like you love to see
that passion mm-hmm what yeah so we're
getting to basically now they're talking
about four seconds outlaws and they
bring new life into the old worlds so
they're kind of changing applause
sectors they're changing up kind of some
of your daily activities there's the
whole thing of spider and he's kind of
your main dude you talk to four right
the tingle chore I think and he's the
one who's part of the flake a the
prisoners got out all the crazy stuff
happened and some of the prisoners got
out to other
places yes now is you gonna wander
around you might find them as public
event bosses you might find a message in
them roaming enemies you might find them
in lost sectors like so there's gonna be
more of the spillover of the reef to
everywhere which is good I was like when
they take it you know take in and it
went everywhere like it was good and
gives it a better feel of a world excuse
me this world changing event and that's
what they need more of they need to have
like okay the Takens out taking craps
everywhere
okay the prisons out okay prisoners are
messing everybody up so and meanings and
like they're seeing they're spreading
that stuff out yeah I agree I agree and
that was one of the you just nailed it
because that was one of the big
complaints with Osiris the DLC because
it felt like such a self-contained story
that didn't have anything to do with
anything or effect basically affect the
rest of the Destiny world right it was
just is so self-contained and to see
stuff like that with these guys are
getting out and calling places and doing
stuff that's kind of cool yeah so you'll
see them everywhere
there's gonna be a new triumphs for
actually hunting some of these specific
ones down um so you'll be crossing them
checklist off try and actually go find
them also give you a reason to go to
different places different times do
different activities just more reasons
to go through but they also said there's
gonna be outlaws and those actually seem
like the big boy versions of these yeah
so we got a little video teaser as they
go through a loss sector and it
literally changes up the lot I mean a
lot of Titans pretty specific because
that's the one you see right and
normally the one site you just have the
one over you melted you go pick it up
you're done very straightforward this
takes that loss section cranks it up to
basically a heroic loss sector if you
want to think about it that way
mmm-hmm and it's gonna turn it into
something with a different task you've
got the quote summoner that you need to
get to which is the wizard but it's
basically in a invulnerable shield well
you take on this massive huge spongy
health ogre
who's gonna mess up the room there's
more guys coming through there's a
Shrieker involved later like they take
the lost sector and just flip it on its
own okay like this is gonna be the
esoteric or what I'm gonna try and do
like these are gonna be solo challenges
because these are gonna be rough yeah
absolutely absolutely and I like that it
adds that letting a different layer to
extra level of difficulty people
and playing things are too easy okay you
know and I even like the fact that um
you gotta be even a certain level to
even be able to deal with some of these
bounties that spider once you cut in
these outlaws so chain outlaw sectors
pretty cool you know a nice little touch
to it to add that extra tension that you
know saying difficulty level I love
stuff like that yeah so there's gonna be
three different tiers you know travel
across each location do different things
he's like and then you'll have the
newest one and that's the outlaw one so
that specific one is what we're talking
about so they said they're able to play
through two different ones ones on the
European dead zone they said they were
going through but the second one they
said they flat-out died and honestly the
devs were happy they're like yes like
they were happy they made something
difficult that it wasn't just like walk
through and do it they want to make this
game harder which I'm okay with
but still I was like as long as it's
harder within a reason of not being just
like I guess what I always hated was
being like worth 32 in dark below and
the enemies were straight-up 33 it's
like I hate the artificial like make it
harder more enemies or you got like
mechanics where you got to go through
waves and all these things come around
and you got to be moving and mobile that
stuff fine but don't just like I'm gonna
smash you a little bit harder because
you can never get to my level that
always kind of annoy me in the end game
life that being said they actually sound
like they do have some cool mechanics in
this too because they said they've got
little shanks that would drop bombs did
you pick up the bombs and throw them at
him it's like that's what I want more
mechanics coming into this so and this
is just in like lost sectors and little
things so those are sound really cool
and they're learning they're learning
man they learn it really are I love it
and like I said I love this difficulty
so I feel since war mind since
escalation protocol that difficult
content that is okay I got a level I
gotta come back you know me had you know
full like just those type of the thought
process behind making stuff very
difficult with also the combination of
great rewards that to me is like the
essence of the destiny grinder people
love right when they get in that shotgun
whatever
now if they just translate that based on
paper what we're hearing with um these
law sectors outlaw sectors all this kind
of stuff the spider stuff I like the
idea of not being strong enough to go
kill go after certain people just yet
and you just kind of building your way
and it's that sense of accomplishment
when you have it so this is the track
and I think they're getting it I really
do
so I mean this paired with your weekly
resets happening more often now I'm
still trying to figure that out because
I forget who I was listening to it's
like is the weekly reset just gonna be
twice a week cuz it's seven days for a
week obviously but they said it was four
days right four days gonna have that
thing on just an oddball rotation all
the time or is it like half the weekend
half the week some cunning curious how
that four day rotations gonna go these
and potentially say these things come up
every four days you're gonna have stuff
to do all the time I mean everybody
works done the week okay do a little bit
on Tuesday okay basically you got a full
reset over the weekend yeah I mean you
basically just jump in just more
frequently now
so that's honestly it's kind of like
kinda wewe feeling it I'm I'm I to it
yeah there's this little person inside
me goes like both sides of your
shoulders like I don't know like they
have they had these pieces in place like
lost sectors were like hey here's a
here's a lost sector okay it's a little
place to run through and pick something
up okay now we're doing stuff with those
hey we've got public events okay now
you're gonna have like great world you
know prisoners coming out there it's
like they're finally starting to add on
and they're finally getting to building
this world out again so know if you
hadn't had a chance to play it's going
to be a lot of stuff so I know you're
saying cat daddy fat stacks by the way I
don't say that ten times fast I just
shouted about he was a girl you better
get on he boxes his channel let me tell
you something man this man tell you how
to get the knife all done this man will
tell you where chests are like he
very beginner friendly for people
obviously he for people who experience
yes but definitely got a shout shout you
out a little bit but you're fantastic
with that kind of stuff and just what's
good about it bounces care that is that
sometimes he'll give you the most
efficient way and I'm saying to go about
doing something and he's very good at
explaining so check my man out you know
yeah we could plug some other people you
know I'm saying but um can you think of
anybody guys in the community right now
it's from a very advanced level if
you're coming in right now yeah you know
I mean this there's the great you know
I'm saying you have you know the
cactuses and the you know the dados and
you got ya unknowns I mean all those
guys have awesome guides and stuff out
there so yes livin it comes to raids but
yeah I mean lately I'll do I'm gonna be
it like nightfall solos if you're
looking for Kade stashes your weekly
resets of stuff to do but if you got me
any questions like hit me up on Twitter
yeah always happen let me and you go and
get direct access team your specific
question you ain't gonna get that kind
of love I'm just pumping my man
so yeah just I mean the lost sectors is
a thing that was kind of like me like
outlawed lost sectors if they get some
twists in there man outlaw lost sector
with like renown now that's one of those
times you better get more than just like
10 by the way can I have a checkbox to
like Auto dismantle Blues or just not
send them to my vault like lasers right
when I get so that like soft cap that
hey if I pick one up cool but if I
forget one don't shove my postmaster
once you [ __ ] failure very they got they
got a working at a blue overload is
crazy it's just a bit ridiculous that
guy kind of looks awesome them can I
have his stuff let's go so next we got
tangled sure this is just it was came
out earlier in the week some of you guys
may have already seen this one but it
was just the way they walked through and
kind of explored it and you got the feel
for it this is where a decent amount of
the campaign's gonna take place
it just looks cool like you've got the
random floating boulders strapped down
with bungee cords and holding it down
the background the skyboxes you look off
the edge and it's just space just
between these two places both tangled
Shore and the Dreaming City I cannot
wait to say that I was like they are
going to look amazing I don't want to
touch - they're aiming city too much you
go on they'll and but let me untangle
sure first you've got the reef it's our
first time to explore it all of the most
of do you want we had it but first time
to actually go wander around most of it
you've got to feel this just literally
you're wandering around in space like I
hope you got a helmet because we ain't
breathin out here type situation and
it's just the world is out here
exploring it's got you got the
tumbleweed Western feel we're gonna have
the prison involved as a part of it just
say that world there's a strike that is
a prison of elders type of way mystic
feels man yeah now is it I wonder if
like 20,000 times three like I've got
here we go
if it has a little variety to it cool
but I was like most of your barons are
gonna be hunted in here so you're gonna
have adventures to explore and both of
these places are not small you get the
tangled shore with enough and with
enough space to do eight different
adventures or at least six depending on
where they move all the Barrens
that's a decent of space already and
then on top of that the campaign going
through there and then a whole other
space necessary chime gonna use let you
take the lead on dreaming city cannot
wait till I get there yeah this is extra
special for me because when I first got
destiny first character class warlock
first race awoken I was just drawn to it
Aled I just you know whatever mod dealt
with the character reminds me you know
the blue skin and all that it kind of
minds me of like cuz I'm a big Silver
Surfer fans for a mind like a Norrin
Radd kind of feel skin do it I'm rolling
with it so now that kind of as I always
wanted to know more about that lore like
you know why I remember reading some
coming doing some buy stuff and hearing
some Island games and they're talking
about the race and there's a lot of
different low-end intricacies to it you
say that whole race so to learn about it
to be in their home world and I'm also
curious about how Zavala reacts to this
cuz technically right he's awoken
this is his homeworld below before
whatever so um you know obviously
doesn't remember the pre-primary the
previous life he lived but it's just
interesting to see you know how to take
tackle that and then from a visual
standpoint man Oh shot the true awoken
for like yo that's my may write that is
is that was the first class that
everybody it just looks so cool so on
yeah man from what I'm understanding you
know this awoken thing that the devs are
talking from a perspective of like
you're gonna feel like you're in some
like almost like a futuristic elven city
you know it's just gonna keep changing
and open the rains gonna be there now
it's just the one I believe that's the
size of NASA's they said it's planet
we've got now that's a huge skybox to
play with so the secrets then the fact
that he evolves over time things changed
more see this is next level we can use a
sparrow
you don't really like man I can't wait I
can't wait I am personally excited about
this and having let's be real like this
the first time a raid has a dedicated
space as well so um I'm ready like this
just the one right here is this this is
for me all the way now that is not for
you either way this is so me let's get
it yeah I mean that's kind of the cool
part is a campaign leading into this
next area which is mostly in-game stuff
and just the fact that's area you can
explore the rate is technically in there
too just an in-game patrol level world
just the people you bump into and be
like oh okay I can't fight you yet
you're quit like that doesn't exist and
has not existed in destiny too and it
really was barely there in d1 except for
a couple parts where you went around to
the wrong cave on
crap where was it cosmodrome I would on
that one ochre sitting in a cave and
you're like oh crap
hey everybody yeah he's over tucked
behind a cave and then when you went all
the way around to where the strike was
for the fall and saber strike when you
weren't on that strike and you went
around there those guys were question
marks if you went early enough to
exactly that's the old feel like you're
not supposed to be here you had that
level I love that kind of state oh yeah
I mean there's a reason actually be like
okay somewhere for me to come back to is
your reason so see what else we got for
now here's a question I want to ask you
and we're gonna bring this article up so
you can see it do you think we get too
much from Bungie before we actually get
the game um here's what I feel I feel
that um I thought about this some more
because I know this is a big talking
point for you I know me and you go back
and forth on it we have a little
disagreement with the Cain death reveal
um here's one I actually have a mini
issue with Game Informer with them kind
of telling a little bit too much yeah
shoutout to fireteam Chad Destin the
gearing those guys they kind of Destin
brought up say look we only gonna cover
supers and then say hey but home you
know I get it you know there's some
people that's like you know I don't want
to know the thought process behind the
spider I don't want to know you know
certain narrative things that are being
explained to us you know even with the
cave stuff I get that so I actually
think it's there to bring out the only
thing mean you are as obviously decatur
view and the reason why i've really come
along with it now is because one they
had to sell it we talked about that but
the second thing is the vibe I'm getting
as big as a shock that is and would have
been if we didn't know the vibe I'm
getting is where this is leading to and
shout out to unknown player you know I
don't obviously we're gonna have to get
some retribution or Elgin can we at
least you know I can I put that okay so
that has to be included but there's a
bigger arc than even that and that's the
curiosity you know I'm saying and I'm
not gonna touch that right now
you know because obviously people have
talked about it the speculation you know
and there's a lot of stuff going on even
by the Bungie deals are kind of planning
on the speculation if you know what I
mean you know my husband's tattoo and
his question and yeah and she yeah yeah
I don't wanna say but you know exactly
you don't say so
people are spinning and I think maybe
even bigger and deeper than we thought
and again this is me putting my trust
I'm blaming myelin games if it doesn't
if it overall been there long but I'm
blaming you cuz you down you're helping
the lower team and you're helping the
raid team and what are your points was
you wanted a conduction conducive story
continuous flowing story into the Ray
that ends the narrative Lee that all the
way so if they doing that I'm good with
it
so here's your counterpoint to shut me
down no I mean you were saying like Game
Informer's dropping a lot of stuff like
I don't mind being late what they've
done for the teasers for the tangled
short that was cool
I'm actually okay like getting a little
like not seeing every little nook and
cranny but just getting a feel for it
talking about it cool um the one like
concept art of the Dreaming city that's
like enough for height but not too much
yes let me give you an idea of Emma it's
just like a World of Warcraft like you
get it like you know a two-minute video
and there's like two seconds of a blip a
video I've seen a different zone like
that's not much but it's like oh it's a
it's like just enough to get hyped leave
the damn guns out of it they're the one
of those few things we get to earn I
don't want to know I'm which one I would
like the guns are one of those just the
stuff we can earn we don't like armor
unfortunately I still my big thing I'm
gonna be pissed when armors just new
years the more armor you know you know
I'm gonna explode with it well ok armor
may be ok but there's no set bonuses
which they even said that I think in the
questions which kind of sucks there's
like triumphs to see if you got the full
set
like that's fine but what if I have the
full set give me a perk but the few
things that we get our exotic guns that
are truly special yeah just the fact
that this one here we I mean it's got a
cool story behind it release this
article afterwards release this later
have an in-depth thing oh you know what
I agree with you on that because we rely
and this thing comes out is it September
yeah and I like the full detailed
description I've seen gameplay of this
thing and this is like okay this is just
another one to add to the list I know
how it works and it may feel kind of
cool but I already know it's there yeah
yeah and there's only gonna be so many
it's not like a full d3 release they
said like 10 to 15 exotics so it's less
than probably we've got four d2 so far
mm-hmm I feel you on that and I think I
mean it's a it's it's I see the plus of
the monitor because Game Informer does
such a good job with these kind of
expose days they did it with rise in
firing and I actually you know it it's
great traffic let's just keep it real
like wine in your thirst to see what's
the next thing they're gonna talk about
you know I I do I think you are over all
right that I think it's a little too
early it should probably be done way
closer to the release window and maybe
some of the narrative stuff maybe even
you know at the window or at write put
you know past it yeah I kind of think so
no I'm maturing it I'm with you on that
part like I said I think I've come
around with you on that I've just like I
said I still take overarching story with
the cave that specifically I think it's
because there is way more in store and
the rabbit hole gets deeper that's
that's my oh my god is telling you yeah
and that may be true I'm not actually
arguing that to any of you any piece but
you know like if it was in the moment
when are you play God of War there are
moments like in in all games but when
you have those moments those cinematic
like epic moments there's nothing
touches those here's the thing I know
it's gonna get bigger I'm just
yet not all right I know either we fight
nested in small it's very angry freshmen
it's cool but here's the thing no they
are not in position like they have to
hit like the Forsaken flops so imagine
the other way let's have it your way
right and I know rent we have to our
marker gotta cut this short
oh yeah we are you know the thing is if
they didn't have it and we didn't know
right what would really be the incentive
to buy Forsaken be real I say we didn't
know and it just shows you know wolken
city you know it just shows falling in
the back I think the narrative was
different man I think I think there's
nothing all here come destiny would
reuse assets
I hate again they really are you ain't
got nothing new you know what are we
doing back at the reef like the context
is different like shout out the Jew in
the chat shout out the I know people
that when they saw it they said oh no
they kill oh my oh we got to go get
people people Oh Jim is a public enemy
number one okay so no let me let me ask
you this if they made it more a question
mark so say they had like you know the
opening trailer you've got like and they
don't show the side of the gun so you
know exactly who it is say you have like
aldrin and you can only see him from
lake and it's got like kind of a
silhouette you see him like kind of got
somebody pointing down looks like
somebody's on but you cannot tell who it
is straight up cannot see it okay okay
isn't they have like a then they have
like a blip of like Zavala or I Korra or
Kane and then you hear the gunshot but
you have no idea you'd still be pissed
at Cade but you don't have the absolute
for sure knowledge of who it is
so there you wanna whodunit you wanna
cosmic cool down I was like but it's
just like but it still would leave more
question to be like as opposed to in
that moment as opposed to going through
the missions and you're like oh I got
this thing going on oh okay just waiting
for it to happen going through the story
Oh
have at least some question going there
are other ways to build - I'm not saying
they did not yes so like it's a favorite
character and it's a good way and they I
can't argue they needed it because I
haven't argued that they needed it and
it's been that push it's been it like
the story push paired with gambit I
cannot argue it's not there but for me
just those moments to experience on my
own that would be like Oh held like that
moment I know I altar now and I'm still
going through the story there's a
different motive and stuff like that but
in that moment that [ __ ] I'm like Oh cup
weave in it well I'm just going straight
through this story until I don't sleep
so I get like it's slightly different
Drive if you don't know it beforehand
shout out the edge of the chat like look
it yeah man I didn't want to do [ __ ] I
don't wanna do [ __ ] with this game and
then that do kill cage I know I know
listen me true he is a very used to be
like yo I remember when Osiris came out
he was like [ __ ] I'm down with this game
he's like I threw it in the bushes
shout-out to camera uses it they do this
game in the bushes they were like we
don't care it was it was almost like
they had to they had to get galvanized
community in some way and that i'ma Kate
is everyone's favorite no one would I
can if I should say that your daughter
the impact would be less maybe they
bring Osiris back to the temple
Zavala you know yes it will have some
effect you know but at the end of the
day they were in the position that the
main thing I liked about it is that the
whole the game doesn't end with that you
know I'm saying rekt' I do like that it
like that's like almost thing the rocks
are that's the catalyst that literally
and we gotta find out why dude is flip
and why's Aldrin doing this like we
didn't have all these a lot of question
you know the Queen is it so much though
so I get it from a hardcore gamers
perspective and from a true now respect
perspective yes you are right maybe they
should not have revealed that and the
shock value it's even harder like a true
single play a narrative game right but
as a multiplayer game where you getting
whole community involved you know I'm
saying like dude you needed something
you had to get that spark that emotions
we go kill just oh we did what you know
that that's just i see the effects I
mean it worked and honestly I don't know
if Bungie did it or other people did a
little memorial they had for him oh it
knows crazy that is even crazier I gotta
know who did hear that that hit me and I
was like this character has that effect
like it really hit me and just just
doing the standpoint of think about this
the way they even said to it just kind
of dope there's not gonna be an
immediate replacement for him no it's
gonna be no hunter Vanguard for a while
Hadi circumvent that we'll see what that
adds that emotional impact me I'm saying
yeah it's a baby a little cheap but
maybe a little Hollywood II I see where
you're going but this kid if that
forsaken fails bro we may not have a
flashpoint
what's the trump card in this game that
we said we're doing a podcast nuts and
we're sitting there watching them build
this thing break break
bringing d1 bricks back in new cool
things we get excited we're at the
moment man and my thing is I'll
sacrifice my personal narrative
single-player want forgetting the
community back already to our but that's
it but yeah I get you though trust me I
don't I don't want to say that I don't
get you I really do I do understand what
you say yeah and even award in my chat
it's like well it's like and it's kind
of a feel now it changes the tone and
that's kind of what I heard from some
people too it's like is it this moment
like now you're gonna be chomping at the
bit for it to actually happen which is
gonna be a little different you
he's in trouble as this we're all right
okay not quite yet being on it whatever
that first like mission or true yeah you
gonna be looking at him every he
stumbled over that rock don't do that to
me award may next year is getting my
heart out so don't do that
he's sucking is like infinity or and
he's like when when somebody might go
down I'm like dude may next year I'm
gonna just I'm gonna be a box of Kleenex
for myself I'm just gonna stock it's
gonna be crazy so little teaser on this
gun we won't go into too much details
because if you haven't seen it don't
spoil it it's honestly just like a
Frankenstein in a bottle auto rifle and
it sounds like you're gonna have to be a
little closer to use it if you want to
get full use out of it because in the
world it feels like somebody got stuck
somewhere shoved a whole bunch of parts
together it may not be the greatest it
kind of worries me and like the story
but that's the kind of stuff that I'm
like hey that's actually kind of cool
but that's one of those when Bungie goes
through and does they're like raid
walkthroughs yeah that's this is the
type of time I want that type of story
give me just like a little UNC slip like
later on and let Bungie be like hey
here's one of our exotics some of you
guys may have it but here's a new one
here's some story behind it cool and I
know game informer I gotta get some
stuff for theirs but I think they
probably got plenty without spoiling
another exotic it's just one of those
that and we could probably do this every
single release how much is too much
they're really good at building the hype
train but they're also really good at
ruin someone's ruining some of my fun
you're the classic case of it was funny
is I literally simply subscribe to it
can you say when it comes to video games
like well that thought process right I
don't want to be I want to be surprised
I don't want to know nothing I want I'm
normally with you it's just like I said
just a state of destiny I'm just so
happy my mandrew playing like I'm happy
you know you know Frodo I people in the
clan it just died off destiny to be
honest I didn't even think this would do
I'm more
shocked that the people who were part of
the community or like y'all I'm in that
I was like I will say the reaction and I
was like it's a big gamble cuz like you
can only do this once and they've said
that you can only do this to cave your
faith one-one-nine which also means
you've also got to make me care about
the others more right and adds even more
weight so I haven't and you can't cheap
bring him back either he's no mm-hmm
yeah acts out the l-boogie the chest is
likely people not gonna matter a quid
keg or facts is it's gonna have a motion
away and I like the way to here I like
the fact that you know we're not they're
not giving them a place you're gonna go
to that spot and the homies gonna be
gone and it's going it's go ahead you
know really I just lost the whole video
dude my videos I'm like but I was like I
guess they're just phasing those out or
nobody's gonna take them over like
videos be toast I'm like damn chitchat
please hit up he watches k videos body
while they still in case you're missing
them like on mods which you already all
have too many of at least go spend your
money on that case - give them some
money let him go down with a pile of
money yeah it just seems like a
hodgepodge the Cerberus plus one just
seems kind of weird so it's literally
it's like three barrels look good for is
better it's kind of crazy not the most
accurate probably not a PDP gun honestly
yeah definitely gonna be more of a PvE
like you might pair this thing with a
scout rifle or a pulse in your range
this will be your medium feeler like I
need a lump sum like pump some weird
shaped bullets going into some people
just just a contra spread gunman that's
how it's gonna work up close is gonna be
really deadly as it goes farther away
the spread probably be weaker unless uh
DPS yeah so a cool one I will give it
this mmm it actually feels very unique
yes so listen we gotta get Bungie what
credit is cooking a gun play man when it
comes
so yeah go sorry no no just just those
unique designs and in the things that
did the weapons teams come up with these
unique power fantasies and weird guns
like you know game doing this man we
gotta give credit where credit is due
much we complain marketing team gun
design art design in my second sound not
even close with these other games ain't
doing it like that's where they keep you
coming back
there's nothing please like that you
know what I would say about like I saw
the ornament come through for MIT and
multi-tools like RIT minimal D tool it
just doesn't have anything special to it
anymore
mmm-hmm I know it's just like your
standard minta workhorse but like its
outgunned in PvP mm-hmm PvE it really
doesn't have much of a point some of
those I still just like yeah some still
need a little love that one that one for
me is just like it's just another scout
rifle and I feel like nameless midnight
even goes more than mid a multi-tool now
it's like it's just got nothing for me
anymore and it's like that sad I'm gonna
spend it a little bit not back I said
balance patch coming we got a bit
balance patch coming on weapons they
warned them and super adjustments gonna
be a super big tweak just like they did
with taking King old classes old weapons
trust me I mean weapon archetypes I feel
they know high-impact Scouts and scouts
right now in a bad place in general with
Kravitz running around is not a pulse
that's just the wait let's keep it range
rate up scout so I got I got faith and
wisdoms genus Outback steam they're not
gonna let this thing run crazy yeah so I
think that's most of out for you guys I
think that kind of covered our topics
we're trying to make these a little more
reasonable an hour and a half at a
minimum good today man I mean you got
the giant bomb cast they're huge but I
mean but flashpoint sometimes Felix they
have to cut a little short so we're
trying to work on that fall between an
hour hour and 20 min we're at hour and
21 oh yeah not bad reasonable not too
terrible yeah so we've got
literally summer of solstice starts in
like so you got the 17th we have two
more clubs but more summer solstice
lives maybe you thinking we got only two
flashpoints before summer as well right
so you think we say next week is for cuz
I is it next week uh factually as well I
think it actually comes back next week
if I'm not mistaken yeah
iron manners this week we're actually
should be next week right it's actually
Riley and 1.2.3 yeah one point two point
three so then they got the prestige
ahead layers coming so that's gonna be
there yes hold on let me find that
picture have it dated yeah that's all
coming back yeah here we go
17 the 23rd patch 1.2.3 final faction le
supremacy is gonna be your crucible
playlist because they're switching that
up to only be in that rotation 24 it's
the 30th faction rally winners week that
might be actually when they drop all the
news because the winners week is pretty
mild mm-hm
but yeah one of those two it's got to
happen because July 31st solstice going
yeah I'm actually gonna be out from the
25th of 23rd so I really hope it's not
there otherwise we're gonna be with
someone like crazy day yeah said being
plays the only reason to come back story
short is that I've been weapons and
tools but the gameplay similar to any
other shooters and and that's what they
got over everybody else it's just it's
so good man and like I said with this
new direction I like to spark a tone
with the story
I'm loving it loving it yeah I was like
and then I sit there nice thinking i
watch anthem and while the gameplay does
look fun it is so like third-person just
kind of a machine gun pointing at it it
doesn't have the I mean the flying
actually looks like it feels pretty
alien but the guns themselves like
firing every single gun in destiny is
just a dress has its unique piece and
even if I was leveling up my hunter just
on my birthday a little mini stream and
just going through even just a little
pariah a little auto rifle that you get
it's like do it just feels right it'll
be alright man uncommon age the gunplay
I just working on the Polaris I finally
stopped being lazy and working on a
provirus Lance question I need
yeah I finally got the legendary version
of it I'm like damn this is even good
too
you know say so it's like this things
feel different feel good everything
feels unique has its own place and then
are you thinking about different
loadouts finally got my Darcy catalyst
I'm happy about that you don't say it's
just man and then you got PDP you don't
say it just destiny has so much going
for it I said if they just keep on this
path correct what they need to correct
you know I'm says I look at that new
raid you already know they talk about
bosses - oh man it's just this setup you
know they're set up right now the way
they're going to really try to bring
this thing back so we call monitor we
hook it in a little bit but we excited
so trying to stick into a plan
definitely not as crazy as last week
kept it to under an hour and a half but
yes sir
if you guys don't catch it you want to
go back and listen to it or just share
it with your friends we'll always have
our archives both on your channel and
mine
check us out subscribe to our channels
guys follow us on Twitter or do feel
ridiculous sometimes I make things in
the kitchen sometimes I'm playing video
games so you never quite know what we do
but boxes hey I like my cheesecakes all
right hey Matty
all right like what was the last Friday
morning for summers birthday it was a
stuffed french toast or like are you
kidding me I'm like you gotta stop my
life is amazing I would not have it have
anybody else so thank you so much you
guys I really appreciate you coming in
listening there would definitely love
doing it we still love doing this thing
we still got that love for destiny but
uh got your outros I cut you off there
man what's up my man no twitch calm Evon
test Twitter TV or twitch.tv of on test
we're cops what com its Yvonne just
everywhere just every ONC is trying to
let's see if I can finalize my logo here
I know it's been draggin that it was
like I'm just trying to finalize like
little mini tweaks but I was like I'm
basically there so banners logos all
that stuff will be changing here soon
finally looks a little better working a
little intro for my videos trying to
look a little professional
good looks oh wait I see anybody seen
each other looks really good I can't
wait from the budget so I'll give you
guys a little peek while you're doing
all this cool little exclusive peek not
that one crap hold on basically gonna
look something along the lines of pretty
close to this so they got the cheetah
get the watermark in the background but
I've got options actually I'm working
with the artist that I am I've got so
the small head logo and by the way if
you guys got any thoughts in chat on
this by the way please throw any
comments on theirs and some final tweaks
so mo go for like Twitter twitch stuff
like this just whatever is a circle
Google gonna be local head being
aggressive or tame I guess sitting down
in the wheel the aggressive what he was
way argue with me about gay deaf as what
that represents
now you're one dusty - I'm pissed yeah
but yeah this one I like so I could
actually have it laying down and then
actually have the watermark in the
background so either way this is pretty
much what I'm leaning towards so
something pretty close to looking a
little video intro but that's just a
little tease for you guys that has come
in so pretty close artist did an awesome
job he put up a whole lot of tweaks for
me and basically not a logo but about
four different ones so patient dude but
yeah definitely a nice looking stuff so
that's fine
along with it whatever what about you
yeah man this Sunday I was you know
actually a social media before we're
getting all I at Lord comfortable so you
already know you know say so on xbox
live the Klan is popping right now we
are now officially on board podcast clan
please look for us on bungie.net we're
actually recruiting we got a couple of
dedicated hardcore trials and glory
players that we just signed two
contracts we try to go to the lighthouse
man we would actually only deficiency
and claim great writers you know and we
have people that play consistent now but
just trying to get the PvP scene so my
boy attacked he just got signed
DCD or he's in there you know these guys
are really good you know I got chance to
play them a bunch of times and maybe I
could get carried I'm good
above average in a very very solid high
level player in standard crucible but
we'll compare Isles that's enough I
dropped down to average so I like to
play more of a support role down the
deal so definitely I get that pop in but
um yes far as our destiny been almost
full-time with it back again getting my
catalyst crying being getting stuff done
before content release as far as on this
Sunday I'll see the Lord's will return
to the round table in the realm on the
technique network we'll be there Sunday
1:00 p.m. Eastern we will have special
guests southbound
nobody knows exactly what it says is
huge the Xbox community good guy and um
yeah we've been talking a good friend to
the realm so it's gonna be real funs we
really should have some fun topics will
be hilarious Lord King north addict
north solve will be in the building so
Sunday 1:00 p.m. the inner circle
Network make sure you tune in and
obviously flashpoint is here on iron law
podcast please subscribe to he bounces
his twitch channels well and his YouTube
channel cat daddy that's for you because
you need those beginning walkthrough so
make sure Yeti with that and we have an
assault like gosh you know flashpoints
is still here we're still rockin on
Fridays with that what content also will
be coming to our Lord pocket try to keep
you guys more programming on our
personal channel as well alright guys
well thank you for tuning in we'll be
back at it next week try and keep this
little mirrors and we'll watch Twitter
watch our watch everything will be back
you got questions hit us up yeah I'm
definitely not huge I'll probably answer
you just kind of like when it comes to
friends I'd rather have some awesome
regulars than a whole bunch of people
I'm not that close with so you got any
questions yet about computers or
anything else movies got award in my
chat talking about infinity war I'm
gonna make a prize yeah thank you guys
have yourselves a great one and enjoy
your weekend it was awesome
without peace